[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alimony in Kenya no wildlife
conservation areas they are quiet
[Music]
this all changes when the phone rings
topic açaí the team can be contacted at
all times
we are the first mobile security patrol
virtual team in this part of Kenya
typically an animal is trapped in
approach is near but it can be anything
a lion which needs to be translocated or
a sick zebra but usually just behind
sure our kids include gloves first aid
kit medical supplies plant food drop and
carry life the team consists of a driver
an admit and two ranges once we have
assembled everything we are ready to go
unserved anime
the rolls are not usually failed most of
the time we play through the bush we are
going to see
[Music]
enriched and more to keep them and more
7oz yourself become debilitated because
of the smear snotty - we only have a few
minutes once and must been tranquilized
and it can be very dramatic
complete back in the compound we are
bigger team just one more keeper takes
care of the orphans our lab technician
takes care of the blood walk a Kohana
manages our online presence this job is
important because as is a lot of
conflict to human beings and wildlife
therefore in Division who say fire life
from becoming extinct is very crucial I
loved so much to save lives and see
animals our and that is our calling
that's why I didn't
[Music]
I'm the best female sustained Kenya my
goal is to be the best female rate live
shot okay Natasha is my daughter and we
are best friends
[Music]
my name is massive era I do it 50 my
name is yours - Hyundai vehicles they
also do weightlifting my elder brother
was a weak lifter and there is to
accompany me to the gym just in 1999
there were no women Rick Lifton
so they were asking the ladies to come
in Jane and that's how I joined and we
never looked back I associate with
lifting when I was 11 years old I used
to go with my mom to the gym whenever
she was training at the gym we do many
exercises we have squat the deadlift
bench presses shoulder press do back
extensions when it comes to drink those
conditioning exercises unis laugh at our
energy future
haha I've competed in four Commonwealth
Games for allAfrica games for African
Championships and in one Olympic Games
Natasha one day is going to be where I
am
natasha is a strong lady I can say that
that's why I even thought that I should
introduce her to the spot and motivate
her and push her to be even better than
me and become the top lifter in Kenya
which makes me part of my mom is that
she stands out from the rest and she's a
strong woman I wanted to be lifted
because my mother she was fed me always
and she told me from the first day that
I can make it I can do it my name is
Elvis suit you know I live in Nairobi
that's in Kenya and I'm a cultural
musician way down
state of Georgia down the road
[Music]
down there oh mama no emotion the blood
or just in the water
Danny wants to know if I may know
jakey's da country music was my first
love my parents I think looking back at
it were very unique in a way because
they loved country music they had all
the records and I listened to all the
beautiful music that was there that kind
of like shaped up the person that was to
become later on in my life we identify
quite a lot with country music because
of the message that is in it
family love heartbreak from the coal
mines of Kentucky to the California Sun
I draw a lot of inspirations from
different singers and different
songwriters Garth Brooks Charlie pride
Alan Jackson Don Williams George Strait
rooks and on the list is endless the
struggles they experience are really
universal
[Music]
every time I've gone on stage I have to
make sure my audience are with me and
they get my message and usually what I
want them to feel is the raw emotions of
a song say this though with me as I walk
the streets of my memory I'm just like a
vessel but through me they can feel the
emotions and it has to be real it has to
come from your heart
[Music]
thank you thank you solver in the heart
of downtown nairobi there is a rink that
rink is home to an unnamed ice hockey
team
we haven't found a name for the team but
you just call it kenya hockey team my
name is Bannon as a Garrard country the
captain Kenya I saw a league I decided
to play ice hockey
simply because I wanted to do something
different in Kenya many people we grew
up playing different sports like soccer
and latex
I just want to do something that stands
out
something unique we have around 30
members in our team we compete against
ourselves
so whoever shows up we divide the equal
number of players then you play against
ourselves there's no money nice work in
Kenya unlike in Europe where we have
leads whereby teams can buy players pay
them well in Kenya just beginning in the
next coming years
ice hockey in the big spots currently
many people are joining and you're
hoping to get even more as pain goes
[Music]
our future dream means for our current
team to be featured in the Winter
Olympics I know we don't stand a chance
but just being there
we might prove the world wrong once you
achieve your dreams there's a
satisfaction that comes with it it is
just a good feeling you like okay we've
made it finally
[Music]
music is really really really powerful
in itself and in in what it can do for
you outside of those
[Music]
Korogocho is one of the largest slum
neighborhoods in Nairobi Kenya but due
to extreme poverty there's limited
access to youth arts programs since 2008
a community program called ghetto
classics has been trying to change that
my name is Elizabeth Georgia and I'm the
founder and director of the ghetto
classics program peddle classics is a
program that started off here in
Korogocho
it's about using music to change the
lives of young Kenyans and in particular
those from very difficult environments
and backgrounds and lives her go sure is
hard but we hope that in our space we
are creating a better a better choral
Russia we teach 600 kids a week we have
violence one viola the cellos we have
fruit clarinets saxophones tubers
trombones trumpets we only got French
ones they have a day which is very
exciting
we see that the discipline that comes
with the kind of use
we teach in this case classical music is
something very important for these kids
because it's something they may lack at
home so they play together make music
together that gives them family the
lives of the kids are just so so so
difficult the challenges they face the
being crushed by life having no hope and
everybody around you is just fighting to
survive so we hope that in our space
we're creating a place where dreams can
can be nourished and can grow and can be
fulfilled
you
[Music]